the Joe Rogan experience I live down by
the beach and so for me I've Lodge it
I'm like what am I gonna do when the
tsunami comes
oh that's I'm just waiting for what are
you doing don't you know better I got
the water yeah all right I don't I'm
actually waiting for like waves to just
come straight there beachfront Pasadena
son that high-rise front row just wait
yeah what the [ __ ] happens then if your
address doesn't exist anymore right
right look we all know that they find
these ancient civilizations on Atlantis
but we do find I mean you don't find
that you know they've never found it
laughs but they've found some pretty
cool [ __ ] yeah the ocean yeah do you
ever see those things they found I think
in the Bahamas it's like these stones
that look like it looks like a
passageway like cut stone cut into the
ground yeah yeah yeah these gigantic
stones looks like some sort of an
underground passage or an underwater
passageway it seems like I remember that
I think at one point they were like
probably entrances made of wood or
something that you know have rotted away
yeah underground stones yeah I don't
know no did they identify that those did
they think those man-made do they think
that they're man-made or did or they're
scientists that think that that's an
answer isn't there there's a portion of
that that is absolute that's called the
mini wrote when he wrote yeah so is that
for sure man-made I could swear portions
of it are same [ __ ] though this I don't
know I just reminded me of something I
just heard recently that I did never
it's never come up on here's from what I
remember that there's like a Stonehenge
type structure on the bottom of Lake
Michigan that people found recently
really what the [ __ ] Joe somebody
pharisee radar just went off these kinda
ones I like - I don't like conspiracies
about Epstein's maybe Michigan's stone
people are still alive
that's pretty there's a lot of weird
pictures I've seen of this try and look
up to think that there's like a mastodon
Carver I don't think that's the actual
one whoa take someone to add it to this
but that looks like it was done in spray
paint in 2008
look like a [ __ ] cave dryer oh it's
that but it I don't I just stumbled
across this online while we were on
bacon break classic and I was like what
I've never heard of this I need to start
using some of your guys keywords so I'll
just start searching for [ __ ] I feel
like my keywords are are narrow what I'm
doing my my internet just like in
time-wasting and I'm I'm not getting the
kind of results you guys are getting
[Applause]